c'est une maison du xviiie siècle à deux
pas de la voie express rive droite
cet ancien bâtiment du service des taxes
du vin de bercy est devenue la maison du
jardinage désormais les jardiniers
amateurs de la capitale viendront y
trouver conseils et documentation pour
leur planque de balcons d'appartements
ou de jardin un outil pédagogique sur
l'art des végétaux qui s'adresse aussi
aux enfants
il y à des ateliers de jardinage et nous
allons recevoir près de 7000 enfants
parents des écoles de paris qui viennent
dans l'atelier pédagogique dans la
perdre potager et s'initier à la culture
des plantes avec la maison du jardinage
le parc de bercy est désormais terminé
plus qu'un espace vert dans un quartier
neuf c'est un jardin à facettes
plates-bandes potager arbres centenaires
et même des vignes les 13 hectares du
parc de bercy sont la dernière
réalisation de la ville de paris et
malgré le manque de place dans la
capitale un nouveau parc est déjà en
projet il reste un dernier endroit mon
avis à paris-xii prochaine endroit sera
cesse et autres pots qu'occupe
actuellement la sncf et calberson et qui
se trouve entre la rue cardinet et
tout le long du boulevard berthier sur
le dix septième arrondissement avec le
parc andré citroën le jardin de bercy
est le grand jardin parisien de cette
fin de siècle un espace végétal très
original ou même les policiers se
fondent dans le paysage